I'm Daniel g, the boring part is I'm a
lawyer at a law firm called Sheridan's.
The exciting part is I do
football for my living,
which is actually quite cool and
going back very briefly and to um,
literally all the times that
I used to go to unfilled, um,
as a Liverpool fund with how back
in the day, um, as all you guys are,
I'm sure some football funds,
the things that I always did when I was
a six year old and Stellar's a 37 year
old do is talk about football all day
long if it's in the office or if it's
actually after on the whatsapp chat cause
he gets rid of knowing on whatsapp as
well. Actually if a result
is gone good or bad. Um,
but ultimately the truth is with the
loss of the work that I've done is from a
very early age.
What I actually wants to do was talk
about football and I've been lucky enough
and you'll hopefully see the career
journey to a degree about why and how I
manage to convert myself from
um, uh, regulations lawyer,
which doesn't sound as sexy to a
football lawyer, which sounds a bit sexy,
but all it is is a regulations
lawyer in football. Um,
and what I wanted to also talk about
firstly as a little bit about my journey,
but as importantly, um, the type
of stuff that I do day to day. Um,
and the very nice, um,
impact that my book,
which has just come out
recently has had on that.
Now apart from my mum being very excited
about the book being published, um,
it's been, it's thankfully been
quite well received so far.
And what I want to try and talk about
in a little bit of detail or some of the
sort of myths that I try
and dispel in the book.
Usually the first thing that most of my
friends and even my family still ask me
is actually what do you
do as a football lawyer?
So what is it that you
do that pays the bills?
That's cool enough to say that you're
a football lawyer and I'm working the
football industry doing so. Um,
very briefly it is as follows,
on a day to day basis,
I tend to work with players and agents.
So that is what I do.
Um,
that tends traditionally to be behind a
computer, but very often is on what's up,
um,
is on my phone is on voice messages that
come to me sometimes at four o'clock in
the morning.
So I'll give you one just brief example
of what happened to me the day before
transfer deadline day.
So Wednesday evening,
I won't obviously disclosed
con confidential stuff,
but just to give you a flavor of what
tends to happen very often is a message
will come to me from a client that
may be a club or a player, an agent.
Usually it's an agent or a club saying,
um, right this, this is happening,
a deals happening on this particular day.
We need just to have a look quick look
through the documents is always what they
say.
And um,
that happened actually at
1:45 AM on Thursday morning,
uh, done. There's a deal that's happening.
You need to go on a train somewhere.
You need to get to the
meeting for lunchtime,
try and conclude the deal in the afternoon
and then hopefully everything we'd
done before, um, deadline
day concludes, um,
on that type of stuff
happens very regularly.
The other cool element that
happens quite regularly is when I,
um,
when I tend to know information
that nobody else knows,
which obviously is very cool,
but I need to be extremely careful
about telling anybody this,
especially because my family are the
biggest Blubba miles of all time as well.
And it happens because I did a
Liverpool transfer over the summer.
I knew a lot of cool stuff that was
going on and couldn't tell anybody.
I'm the brilliant thing about
it also was it was that him,
he was asking me about particular
deals that were going on.
I couldn't even, I couldn't even deny
the existence of what was going on.
So for about a week and a half,
I couldn't even reply to him.
So he thought I was just being annoying,
not replying to the General um,
uh, rumor mill that was going on, Joanie.
But it was actually because one of the
players that I was working with was going
to be signing a deal with Liverpool and
I couldn't even tell my dad obviously,
which is very important because
he obviously wants to know the,
the Gos and what's going on generally.
But needless to say,
as soon as the deal happened,
I could then tell my dad's and my rest
of my family who had no idea what was
going on.
But I still couldn't tell them anything
interesting about what happened in the
deal. Cause obviously it's
confidential too. So the,
the type of stuff that I tend to do is
unfortunately and the glamorous sizes,
great. You're working with so many
fantastic players with great clubs,
they're spending lots of money.
It is without doubt the most terribly
stressful hours of my life on a regular
basis.
When the window is cropping up or
finishing or concluding because you,
you are managing risk on one sense you
want to make sure that the deal completes
because you don't want to be at blame
if it's anything to do with you.
You are still trying to communicate
quite difficult legal concepts to your
clients to explain what the risk
is of particular things happening.
And at the same time also, um, you're
trying to make sure that um, uh,
you are being proactive. You're
thinking about solutions and things.
Generally I'm,
I'll going to plan and that you want to
look unruffled and looking and ruffled
and feeling unruffled are two
quite different things at times.
So that's just a very brief way of
background as to what I actually do day to
day. So about meat. We've had the
intro, this is where it all began,
is the truth. So, uh,
my seat was just above the
director's box about there.
And as you can imagine,
there's this big pole that got
in the way of the goal basically,
which is a problem. So me and my bro had
to, uh, ultimate games have to swap seats.
So one of us could see the main goal
and one of us couldn't for a particular
game, which worked out well.
Now this is the old stadium,
so it's now come to leave the stadium.
So it's, it's slightly better.
How did I get involved in football?
So very briefly,
what happened in law school at
university was the, um, I asked,
my tutor lets you off the cuff,
can I write about the Bozeman ruling?
And the Bozeman ruling was John, what
Bozeman back in the day in 1990, um,
wasn't allowed to transfer to a new
club after the end of his contract,
after it even expired.
And that started a very big landmark case,
which five years later actually resulted
in what's called the free movement of
players across Europe, which meant that
after a player's contract had finished,
they could move on a free transfer
and the selling club couldn't,
didn't have to demand it and couldn't
demand the transfer fee. So I thought,
what a brilliant thing to possibly
in third year uni write about,
which was the bosom and
ruling the transfer system
changing and how things would
work. And they let me write about
it, which is even better after that,
I actually just tried to
persuade my dad's, um,
for me to spend an extra year at uni,
which he was happy for me to do if I
did something interesting. I did a,
a master's in football
broadcasting rights.
It didn't sound as interesting because
actually underpinning it was competition
law, which obviously is not quite
as sexy as football law. Uh,
but at the same time meant that I could
spend best part of about nine or 10
months writing about how broadcasting
rights are sold across Europe,
which is cool.
And it meant that I could go out to the
real world for one more year before I
had to stop working. As
a result of that. Um,
master's degree had little bit
spare time at the end of the A,
which actually meant that my tutor said
to me instead of actually just slacking
off, why don't you write in a couple of
law journals about the things that you've
written about? Great. Okay, I'll do
that. Didn't think anything would happen,
but in a fantastic way.
They money,
they were happy to publish something
about the football industry,
which was broadcasting rights
and about club ownership.
The entertainment law review at the time
published those two articles and a few
in a few months spells. But what's
actually realized afterwards that as,
as well as it was great for my ego.
Fantastic.
Getting the entertainment sports
journal. Um, great to have the publicity.
Fantastic to show a few
people and have it on my CV.
The truth was a domain set battle
against entertainment law review.
Maybe only about eight
people read it is the truth.
And you'll soon find out from a lot of
the talks or rather a little bit the talk
that I give them a little bit of
time is what I actually realized.
As much as it was really good for the
ego because no one was reading it,
I actually needed it to improve,
increase my profile to a degree.
And the way that I actually did
that, I've met my wife Holly, uh,
in 2007 and quite click quickly. Um, uh,
we talked about all the stuff that I
could do in my job and wants to do my job.
She actually then said to
me, well, hold on a second,
why are you writing five or 6,000 words
for an entertainment law journal when
you could be writing 500
words on your own blog, free.
The antibody could be able to then
access and read accordingly and actually
thought, you know, it's
actually a pretty good idea. Um,
and so what I ended up doing was,
um,
not necessarily not writing
in law journals overall,
but ultimately deciding to start my
own website, which has Daniel G. Dot.
Com and then,
um,
effectively start writing small pieces
about trying to demystify the football
industry to a degree.
Even though actually at the time I
wasn't doing a huge amount of work in
football,
I was doing small bets that
there is hopefully increasing
and the type of work I
was doing, but I wasn't doing huge amounts
of that time. And it came, actually,
it's a very fruitful is the wrong word,
but a really interesting time
in the football industry.
There was financial fat play,
which I'll talk about in some detail.
There was third party ownership,
which is a big thing at the time.
Luis Suarez came to the country.
Um,
and obviously he had a lot of um,
issues with racism, with biting,
with suspensions. John Terry
Marta came up as well. Um,
so I, Nicolas Anelka happened
at the same time. So what,
what was actually happening,
which is quite cool as well.
There were lots of cases and
lots of issues that the public,
the wide fund funds really
wants to know about.
And what I had a little bit more time
before kids and marriage was to be able to
read these cases, try and explain what
they meant for the average fund. Um,
and try and get beyond the Louis
Suarez is a racist or um, uh,
it's a three much bond for fouling
somebody or actually if you look at the
detail of a particular case, it means that
or it means this. And what I developed,
um, which was great was quite a strong
follower base on Twitter as well,
which was a great amplifier of my blogs.
Um, to be able to then put forward,
easily accessible, easily
digestible five, six,
700 word blogs that
people are interested in.
And then what happened is his role
to that was that journalists, um,
sky sports or the types of broadcast
media within interested in having me on
their shows really, which
is, which is great. Um,
and that in itself then drove the profile
that I was able to drive for myself
and my firm was able then to um,
refine my message that I
wants to get across to people.
And in turn led me then to that,
which was from blog to book.
So I used to give a lot of comments and
commentary to people in the football
industry.
Someone I'm a journalist says,
why don't you think about writing a book
on the topic? And I said, oh, great idea.
I don't think anyone will actually
think can be interested in it.
He introduced me to an agent's David
Luxton and who is bizarrely my agents,
which is quite strange to say, but
nice as well. Um, and he is an effect.
The miracle worker that got my proposal
that I put to him out to five or six
different publishers.
Um,
there's quite a long process in that
till or actually get the all clear to
actually then get the deal
and to write the book.
And then more or less three years later
from starting to get the proposal to
finishing the book, we are there
with, um, with done deal. So, um,
that is the book that came out
a few weeks ago that, um, uh,
that so far has done really well.
You know,
I don't know how many copies actually
mum has bought in order to actually skew
the, uh, the Amazon algorithm
accordingly. But in any event, um, uh,
everyone's happy at the moment.
And then g household, which is,
which is nice to the extent that when I
told my daughters actually that I had a
book being published, my oldest one
is, he is six and my youngest one live,
he is three and a half.
I told you I was writing a book.
I'm the teacher then at the next, uh, uh,
a teacher's meeting and came in and said,
oh, it was fantastic. That,
um, you know, you've written a,
that you're involved in the book industry.
Um,
I didn't realize that you were a librarian
because Izzy had told her that I'd
become a librarian because I'd
written, uh, written a book.
So that's my new new pastime as well as
being an author and a lawyer. So, um,
book out, um, uh,
and what I wants to share with
everybody for the next 15, 20 minutes,
hopefully if this works all right is
just a few insights into the world of
football,
which I see on a daily basis and what
is covered and uncovered in the book,
but just talking about particular things.
So you'll see at the top transfer fees,
shirt, sales agents, book
deal, so boots, deals,
appearances and ImageRight
some of the more, um,
interesting elements that I
think and hope will be of value.
And please feel free to ask questions and
to delve into some of the things I say.
I think we're going to keep the
questions if possible to the end,
but just hold your questions because
I'm always very keen on audience
participation. So the most you're able to
ask, um, the batter I'm looking at, Tom,
please be careful about the questions
because if you probably know as much as me
about some football stuff, so don't show
me up too much, please. Okay. Number one,
a 35 million pound transfer,
uh,
actually isn't a 35 million
pound transfer. Now,
I know it sounds slightly
counter intuitive,
but I promise I'll try and explain myself.
So when you look at the back page of a
story and the back page of a newspaper,
you'll see player moves for
35 million pounds. Uh, and um,
uh, and that's the, a fee basically that
the club has paid for that player. Yes,
that is the case.
But what I want to drill down to is
actually the liability that the players as
well rather than the clubs the buying
club has to incur for that player. Now,
if a joke's talking about just
the transfer fee for a second,
the transfer fee is effectively the
amounts that's the buying club pays to the
sailing club.
The buying club has obvious,
but what isn't usually as obvious
is actually how that is structured.
So in most deals that I
see and I've come across,
what actually happens is there's what's
called a fixed and a contingent elements
to a transfer fee.
The fixed bit being paid regardless of
anything over a particular period of time,
usually first,
second and third anniversaries of the
transfer and the contingent a certain
bonuses or met certain conditions are met,
which mean bonuses are paid.
So if I give the 35 million pounds
example, it may be, for example,
I'll try and do the math right.
That 50 million pounds is paid
upfront at the time of the transfer.
And then maybe on the first anniversary,
5 million pounds is paid.
Maybe on the second
anniversary of the transfer,
another 5 million pounds is paid.
So that takes it to 25 million pounds.
It may be that for the next 10 million,
in order to be paid,
the buying club has to win. The Champions
League or the buying club has to uh,
win the Premiere League,
for example.
And if those performance
measures aren't hit,
then that's extra 10
million will never be paid.
It actually gets a little bit more
complicated than that because usually what
has to happen is as well as the
club winning those trophies,
the player has to appear in a
certain amount of those games. I,
he has to contribute to that
season's worth of success.
Now that's the first element.
So 35 million pounds doesn't
usually mean 35 million pounds.
It actually can only my Tony mean 25
million pounds on certain contingencies as
a result. The other element, which
is not factored into any of that,
is the play's wages.
Now obviously the players wages
are usually the biggest, um,
liability over the length of the deal.
If a player signs a five year deal, uh,
let's say for 200, 200,000 pounds a
week, that could od over five years.
I to try and do the calculations,
possibly 50 million pounds worth of
liability over and above the transfer fee.
That might only be 25 million.
So the point is,
when you see the headline at the back
page of the newspaper saying 35 million
pound transfer, think actually the first
thing is you might not actually make,
it might not be a 35
million pound transfer,
but actually the main liability
is actually the play's wages.
So 35 million pound transfer may actually
be if everything is included over a
hundred million pounds worth of
liability that's taken into account.
And the other thing that needs to be
taken into account is the agent's fee.
But we'll talk about that
in just a second as well.
So myth number one,
35 million pound transfer isn't
usually a 35 million pound transfer.
It's a lot less,
but also a lot more.
Number two,
I see this quite a lot as well.
I feel I'm spending more time on this
side of the room then this side of the
room, sorry, I'll try
this. Um, is this follows
without fail, pog Ba Latin, um,
Mannette, Liverpool, Salah,
whoever else it may be.
Every time a big transfer happens,
the first thing that you will always
see back in back in the day is, uh,
the clubs will recruit most
of the transfer fee from the,
from the shirt sales that they will then
they will then make as a result of the,
um, uh, as a result of
the transfer. I can,
I can't say categorically that
this absolutely never ever happens,
but I absolutely doubt that it ever
happens for the following reason.
So try and give an example,
and this is only from public information
because Manchester United for example,
of floats in the u s so
they have to provide certain
information to investors on
a quarterly basis. Anyway,
it's reported to that.
Edward would states in some
of those courses, the reports
and what is published,
the Manchester United makes 75 million
pounds a year from Adidas apparel deal.
It makes 75 million pounds a year.
That decreases if they don't get to
the Champions League over a particular
period of seasons. But on the whole
75 million a year, and that's a 10,
I think it's a 10 year deal. So, um,
almost coming up to a billion
pounds for a 10 year deal,
750 million pounds over 10 years.
Now,
what usually happens in these very,
very big shirts deals is effectively
those apparel companies are paying a very
big advance for the right to be able to
then exploit the brand and to be able to
sell those shirts.
Um,
this isn't the Q and a part,
but does anybody think that
Manchester United or help?
So just very quickly,
how many shirts do you think Manchester
United sell on a yearly basis?
Just very quickly shout outs
and hundred thousand higher.
I'm doing a Bruce Force,
I think 15 million shirts.
That's quite a difference.
But it is,
well that's another big question.
Fake or real shirts is that you can put,
let's just say authentic shirts
retailing for over 50 pounds. Uh,
shirts, 5 million. Okay.
So the last figures where I'm
from a season and a half ago,
that Manchester United on a yearly basis
sold 2.9 million shirts or rather rd
does showed or whoever the
manufacturer was 2.9 million shirts.
I'm not sure if that's more than a lot
of people think or less than other people
think. I get varying degrees
of, I'm surprised either way.
The point being that usually what will
happen and those type of agreements is
there will be this advanced,
this is paid every year,
but after that there may not be anything
more paid as a result to the club by
way of amounts.
Usually there will be
performance related amounts,
but that only kicks in after
a certain amount of shirts.
Sales are made on a yearly basis,
so it may well be,
and I don't know that I did.
US Don't pay anything more to Manchester
United per year over the 75 million
pounds mark that they do. I want to say
pay what I mean his share in the revenue,
but let's say for example that Manchester
United and it does share some revenue
after they hit 2 million shirts,
sales a
and usually that share that royalty,
whatever you want to call it,
is actually probably only 10 or 20%
of the overall additional amount.
So let's just, without wanting to
confuse anyone in too much details,
say that actually Manchester United for
every shirt sold over 2 million shirts,
maybe get 10 pounds per shirt.
So you don't need to meet to do the math
very quickly for you to work out that
one of the biggest clubs in the world
are not making huge amounts of money from
shirt sales over and above the amounts
that they're getting from their apparel
manufacturer straight away.
Now the other question to also add
into the mix as well on that is, um,
and it's something that no one's really
done too much empirical evidence then is
would an additional or marginal,
um,
by a marginal fund,
by an additional shirt with
the new player's name on,
or were they already going to buy that
shirt with an existing players name on
which also fits into the narrative,
which is it doesn't mean
that an absolutely new fun
is going to be buying an
absolutely new players shirt.
It may be that they'll buy that shirt,
but we're going to buy it
anyway regardless of which
the player was going to be.
So second meth hopefully dispelled
in a little bit of detail,
which is very rarely, whenever you
read a headline of shirt sales,
we'll make fortunes for the club.
Usually they won't.
Okay.
Sorry.
It's a little bit smaller,
but you can have to strain to be
able to read it. Um, I know the,
the question of agents is always
quite a topical issue generally.
Um, the narrative of
agents is that they, um,
uh,
don't do a great job for players or clubs
that they take too much money out of
the game in terms of commissions and
that their approach is wheeler dealer at
best. I have a slightly vested interest
in as I work with a lot of agents,
but the book hopefully
you'll see as well if you,
if you able to read it gives a slightly
different narrative to the usual
narrative,
which is agents are just bad guys doing
bad things all the time and nobody likes
them or at all the,
the difference with a lot of the very
good agencies that are extremely well
networked, um, uh,
very diligent in what they do
work incredibly hard in a very,
very insecure industry.
And when I mean insecure industry,
I mean devote worked very hard to get
very good players on their books and
probably at every other window and other
agents has trying to poach their player
to say, I can get you a better
deal or I can get that for you.
I can do this for you better.
I'm not saying all of a sudden poor
agent's doing a terrible job on the bread
line,
but the vast majority of agents are not
earning the huge sums that are reported
in the media. Um, the points of
what I'm trying to get to here is,
is that there is an interesting
narrative which works in the media,
which is look how much,
uh,
agents take out of the game and
look how much clubs pay agents.
And this is the thing that I think a lot
of people maybe don't quite grasp in,
in, in the same amount of detail that
I've been able to be able to work with an
industry for some time,
is players don't pay their agents.
So I just want that to sink in for a
second because before I started in the
industry, it seems quite a strange
concept to me is like if I'm,
if I'm a player and how is my agent and
I and how does a move for me to a new
club, I thought that I would pay
him because my contract is with him.
I'll pay you a percentage of my earnings
and that's the way that things work
generally.
But the way that things tend to work at
least in the UK and other countries is
in order to incentivize the
player to move to their club,
the club pays the players agents.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
And that has caused controversy
because on the whole,
that means that funds see
their club paying agents and
they see the amounts that
they pay agents and don't like the amounts
that they pay agents and where it can
get a little bit tricky for the player.
And I don't want to go into too much tax
detail cause it's certainly not the tax
talk and I don't want to get involved
in that type of stuff as well.
But the one thing that
actually then becomes quite
intro already heard someone's
heard too much about taxes as well.
Um,
the one thing that's important just
to stress about that is, is that, um,
that is seen as what's called
a taxable benefit. The,
the club paying the player's agent is
what's called a PLF and d benefits.
It's like what Mel and medical
insurance or a company car would be.
So even though the player
isn't paying his agent,
he has to pay tax on
the club Pangas agent.
And if that is one of the most important
things that I actually see when a
transfer happens is that there's
been so many times when the player,
18 months on from a transfer,
we'll get a big tax bill from HMRC.
And then the, the players say, well hold
on a second. Why have I got a tax bill?
The club has paid, uh, uh,
my, my agent on my behalf.
And then if the agent hasn't done a great
job, unfortunately the agent says, ah,
yeah, but there was still a
tax bill to be paid on that.
And what usually happens for very savvy
agents when a transfer is happening,
we see this more and more, and I'm
sure you guys will have heard of this,
similar to equivalent in the employment
contracts and agent will negotiate
what's called a gross up close and a
gross up clause is morale and a miraculous
payment which comes one week before
HMRC is tax bell comes along,
which means that then the player doesn't
feel the money going out of his account
because it's more or less
going straight to HMRC,
which actually is a very clever
thing for the agent to do,
rarely because otherwise they will.
And I've seen it time and time again,
get into an awful lot of trouble with
the player when the player has to
basically pay half of the agent's fee in
tax to the tax authorities at the right
time. So they're the type of
things that you see day to day,
but the point genuinely being is
whenever it feels counterintuitive,
almost always the player
will never pay his agent.
And we'll talk about what the thing
is in the future that's going on.
I think that's,
that may there's a possibility that
that may change with a new fee for
regulations that are being implemented
next.
Brute deals are complicated. Um, okay.
So just very briefly and I'm
always interested in doing, um,
actually I do use the good at
Google analytics tool for, um, uh,
my website to be able to understand
actually, which are my favorite,
which are people's favorite blog posts
more or less than what I've the most
abused from the,
the blog that I did on boots
deals is by far and away the,
the blog that I've had
my most of you is on,
in my entire history of writing any blogs.
And the reason why I think hopefully
it's hit an interesting, um, um, uh,
an interesting,
uh,
point is most people think that a boots
deal I when a player signs a deal and it
may be for goalkeepers with their golden
gloves as well for their Shin pads and
their boots that all they are paying for
is the ability of the player when they
go on the pitch to use their boots and
Shin pads and maybe have a couple of
appearances on some promotional stuff.
So you've seen Massey last week Pepsi
but he used his idea dust boots as I did
as shoes for the promotional
videos, et cetera. Um,
so it means more or less means this,
whenever I see a boots deal,
if it's with Puma, Adidas, Nike,
new balance underarm or whoever else
it may be in almost every situation.
It doesn't cover just boots.
So just a quick Straw poll.
Who thinks of boots deal
should cover headphones?
Anybody?
Yeah,
to thank you.
You've got a head start there.
The,
the scope of a boots deal is vast
and there's two particular caveats
and carve outs that I see quite a lot.
One is with most manufacturers,
they will try and carve out as much as
possible into their scope that they can
then exploit for the player
to be able to use. So um,
headphones is a big one. Um, shampoo
and shit. Skincare is another big one.
Any types of electrical
goods is another one. Um,
does anyone think Armani
is a competitor of humor
apparently in some boot deals or is it
not getting Puma's but the general point
is,
is that if possible,
what a brand is looking to try and do is
to create the biggest scope as possible
for a player.
Not to be able to endorse anything
else is the truth because it gives them
ultimately a bigger window to be able
to put a dress the player up in all of
their gear all the time.
And also the point worth mentioning as
well is just if you've signed a Nike deal,
for example,
obviously it goes without saying that
you shouldn't be going out wearing Adidas
trainers.
But ultimately the practical reality is
is that if you are signing a long term
Knightdale, you're probably not going
to be able to where I need to add,
I did ask for the next five years
at all. And if you do, bear in mind,
if you do wear any competitor,
and especially at direct competitor,
it's pretty likely you're deal is over,
almost very likely your deal is over.
So that's the one thing on the
brand alignment and scope of points.
The other bit that's quite interesting I
think also on boot deals is the amounts.
So you may have, the agent may
say to the player, okay fantastic,
you're going to earn 500,000
euros a year, um, for your deal.
And the player says, great,
great news, great to hear.
There's one onyx at the back
of most boots deal contracts,
which always scares me whenever I see it.
And the reason why scared it scares me
to a degree is it because it is a direct
table which relates to the amount of
appearances that the player has to make on
a yearly or seasonal basis.
So what usually happens is the table,
if he's an international player,
which the big players are obviously
who are getting the bigger money,
it will say you have to perform all appear
in 80% of your club team matches and
you have to appear in 70%
of your international club
matches and if you don't
the retainer,
which is the overall amount reduces by 40%
and sometimes bigger depending on depends
on how you want to negotiate that.
So one of the important
elements is for two things,
one to try and negotiate
hard hard on those points,
but secondly to make sure the
players aware of that point.
Now there's another question
all of that which is,
and I'll talk about it in
the next slide to a second,
but I want to just briefly mention it
here and this is obviously where lawyers
get involved a lot more. What do you
think the definition of an appearance is?
Exactly. I'm not. All of
that is exactly right.
Is it appearing in the match day squad?
Is it being on the pitch?
Is it starting on the pitch?
Is that ending on the pitch? Is it five
minutes? Is it 10 minutes? Is it 20,
you know,
that is one of the most important went
what I think it might be the next slide
which has gone through quite
nicely, perfect, seamless.
Um, that is one of the
most important, um, uh,
definitions in a contract that I will
tend to deal with because ultimately for a
boot deal, if an appearance can
simply be 10 minutes in a game,
you can obviously imagine that it's very
much easier to be able to get to that
70, 80, 90,
whatever percent threshold in order to
maintain your retainer amount in your
boot deal.
But most importantly in an
employment contract setting,
this is very,
very,
very strategically important for an agent
and a player to know about as you can
imagine.
But usually for two reasons.
The first is when, um, uh, uh,
an agent is negotiating his
player's employment contracts.
There is much more, um, uh, uh,
there is much more consideration given
to variable pay rather than fixed pay as
the husband in previous years.
And what I mean is fixed is you will
get 50,000 pounds regardless if you play
one minute,
whether you're not even in the squad.
And it doesn't matter whether you
play or not, that's the fixed amount.
The player always knows that he will
get that amount regardless of what he,
how he plays or what he does.
What a lot of the elite clubs are
doing now is trying to reduce the fixed
amounts and increase the variable amounts,
which is if you play and if you win,
you'll get more than uh, if
you would have just, uh, um,
how'd your 50 grand amount every month,
every week, and a little bit extra.
So the incentive effectively is that if
you think you're good enough to play an
office team,
you should take a lower fixed amount and
a higher variable amount because we're
good enough,
which means you're going to appear and
you're going to win and therefore you'll
be remunerated better than
you otherwise would have done.
But you can see obviously the point
that I'm trying to get her here,
which then becomes the points
appearance becomes very, very important.
As a definition because the bonus
element for the employment contracts is
appearance fee.
We'll give you a bonus now as you can
imagine then it's exactly all the points
that you said doesn't appearance mean and
it usually does and lots of instances,
uh,
starting a premiere league much,
that's what it can sometimes be
and that can be caveats throughout.
There was a different bonus for starting
a premier league much to an Essay Cup,
much to a Champions League, much to a
League Cup, much to a friendly much.
That's how varied it can be and it can
be different when amounts for all of
those competitions and sometimes there
can be merged together so it's an
appearance and when bonus
in order to get the bonus.
So obviously as you can get to now an
appearance and how that is defined is
crucial as to whether a player
may get the bonus or not.
For an agent,
he'll want to try and make sure that
one minute on that pitch classifies as a
bonus,
as an appearance.
Whereas the club will want to make sure
that it's a start in the first team
squad for particular game,
which means it's harder obviously for
the player to do that if he's injured out
to for whatever else it may be.
The other element of why
when it appearance becomes
very important is because
sometimes in a contract there'll be a
ratchet effect. And what that will be is,
is after you've played in 20 games,
40 games, 60 games, 80 games,
your salary will go up
accordingly as well.
So you may be 50,000 pounds
that you get is fixed.
If you play 20 games for
us and appear in 20 games,
you will then go up to 60,000 pounds a
week and then 870,000 pounds a week if
you get to 40 60 80.
And again,
that's very important for
how you define appearance.
I've talked about parents
who are way too long,
but hopefully you can see
why that actually becomes
quite an important element
for players and agents
and clubs to understand
last bits about dispelling mess a little
bit as well. Um, so I've just been,
just put the phrase out there which is
image rights deals are just another way
to avoid tax.
I just want to briefly
spend we okay for time, um,
a few minutes talking about what's an
image rights deal is for players and then
talking about why it's important in the
current, in the current environment.
So if I just try and uh,
uh, explained very briefly,
traditionally a player will only
have one contract with his club.
It will be an employment contract that
will say you are employed by this club to
play football straight forward with
all of those clauses and all the things
we've talked about previously.
Nowadays for a lot of the elite
clubs with their elite players,
they have a huge raft of partners and
partnership agreements and endorsement
deals that they can activate across
the globe at which are very lucrative
contracts.
And what clubs are realizing
is they are happy to,
well not realizing what they want to
do is control the activities of their
players to a degree so that they can
activate those players for the club to be
able to then activate its own partnership
arrangements over a longterm basis.
So do spurs won a
hurricane to be able to um,
activate a night campaign
for Spurs? Yes, they do.
To a Liverpool wants most solar to be
able to activate a particular campaign for
Standard Chartered. Obviously they
do within the standard contract,
there are default positions where players
have to have x amount of appearances.
But what is happening more and more with
elite clubs is they are entering now
into two separate deals with their
players. One is the employment contract,
but the second is an image rights
contract usually with a player's company.
Yeah.
And what happens in this
deal is the players company
more or less promises to do
two things, which is a real
significant value to the club. One is,
it says for the provision
of x amount of money.
Okay.
Uh,
we the club want to make sure that you,
the players image rights company,
make sure that the player appears in x
amount of endorsement opportunities and
partnership opportunities
for the clubs partners.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
Guaranteed number.
So that means that then
the club's commercial teams
can go out and sell quite a
lot of inventory on the basis of knowing
that maybe that top 15 stars will be
available and are contractually available
to help endorse the club in a club
context.
Yeah.
Not so very important to element.
The other element,
which is a very useful to the club in
paying a players image rights company
is that there are a hell of a lot of
restrictions that then the club can impose
on the player.
So just to give you a brief example,
so I don't know how many
partners Manchester United
hough throughout the world.
Global partners. There's a lot, I mean I,
I'm not sure it's quite 150 I lost count.
I think there was upwards of 90.
So, for example, and just by way of if
it's Manchester United, if it's Chelsea,
if it's Liverpool,
if it's arsenal,
a lot of these clubs have a big roster
of commercial partners and what those
clubs would ideally want from that
players is to ensure that those players
cannot contract with a
competitor of the club brands,
which means that they are effectively
clean from any club competitors,
which then puts them in a strong
position to make sure that their players,
I'll never going to endorse competitors
of the club's brands and that's quite a
valuable commodity to be able
to actually um, use as well.
The flip side,
which is why we talked about tax is the
reason I've said all of that commercial
and explanation is because still there
are always big headlines about the fact
that um,
image rights deals are just a way to
avoid tax because obviously players,
image rights companies
are paying corporation tax
rather than pay as you go pay
as you earn.
And national insurance contributions.
The point being is that even though that
money is coming in and the club under
players, image rights company
is only paying corporation tax,
that money is still in that
club's accounts. It has to. If,
if the player wants to remove that money,
he's either got to pay
it through dividends,
he's got to pay it through salary
to other people through the company.
Hover is there still needs to be Tux
paid for onshore companies that are using
an image right structure.
So my point is I'm not the uh,
the guide that will always say image
rights structures are always totally
inadequate.
It's just another way to avoid tax.
Usually there are very good reasons
why clubs will want to enter into image
rights agreements with that players.
One because it guarantees
them appearances and two,
it means that they can just restrict
the players in promoting competitor club
brands, which can be very
important. Okay. Almost there.
I promise. What's next?
I just wanted to talk,
we've talked actually about agents
already and get your questions ready.
If you have any, any questions as we
go, more than happy to answer anything.
But lots of people, um, actually since
I've released the book of acts, you said,
well, what do you think is
next for the industry? And, uh,
there's a chapter right at the
beginning of the book called, um,
the football ecosystem where talk about
how everything is sort of overlaid
together. So, um, you know, where
the player's fit in with their clubs,
where the club's fit in with the league,
where the leaks fits in with broadcasters,
where broadcast is fits in with
the funds for subscriptions.
Where of our international games was
about fee for new way for and all of these
different ways that um, um, the
football world works. And people said,
said to me for quite some
time and continue to ask me,
is the football model sustainable?
I think that's one of the things
that lots of people say, you know,
football players are being paid huge
amounts of sons to be able to played
football and for their
image to be able to be used.
Is that model sustainable in the longer
term where we have sky for example,
and bt paying five over 5 billion pounds,
um,
for UK rights.
And a whole raft of broadcasters paying
upwards of 4 million at 4 billion for
the overseas rights for life
Premiere League matches.
The query is well how come clubs still
afford to pay all of these wages and pay
these exorbitant transfer fees?
Is the bottom going to come out
to the market at some point?
That's the type of question I get asked
quite a lot and the answer at least at
the time being, and that's why I just
put the broadcasting point that there is,
is that so long as there is an appetite
for broadcasters to spend large sums of
money because they think they can recoup
that money by way of subscriptions in
different models then at the
moment the answer is yes.
But we see, I saw some interesting starts
a few weeks ago explaining that sky.
Um, uh, in the purchasing of the, the,
the rights for Premiere League matches
seem to be straining a little bit in
removing some of their other contents
because they've had to spend so much money
on Premiere League matches and
live Premiere League matches.
And in the same way,
whilst the sky has always
been the incumbent for live
Premiere League matches,
Beatty came into the markets to auctions
ago effectively because they saw quite
significant churn.
They saw churn away from their broadband
offering into sky broadband because
people were already taking a pay TV,
Sky Sports and thought that they should
bundle sky broadband with their sky
sports offering.
So in some ways was a lot of commentators
said at the time was that bt came into
the markets to protect their broadband
offering and then in order to be able to
then get champions league rights and
Premier League rights and then you can see
what's happened subsequently,
um,
bt by e a sky have their own, um, uh,
mobile offering as well. And you have
what's called a quad play offering.
So you have to quad play players playing
out in the UK market for a whole range
of consumer goods. Um, pay TV and sky PTV,
sorry. And the premier league being a
very big part of that overall picture.
So the question is,
at some point,
who knows what will happen is where the
subscription start dropping off because
of the cord cutting generation.
Because people aren't willing
to pay 60 70 pounds a month,
the sky or bt pay TV subscriptions.
The question asked a week ago,
Simon Jordan was on um, um, uh,
talk sport and he said, why don't
the Premiere League just go it alone?
Why don't they just go straight to market
and offer an Ott offering globally?
And I ask people to pay eight,
eight to 10 pounds a month to watch every
premier league much they want and take
away the broadcasters. I've, I,
I wrote a blog about 10 years about that
10 years ago about that exact point.
You know,
quite a lot of major league baseball do
it really well in the states and there's
a real interesting offering now that
could possibly come to fruition.
But the truth is it
would take a very brave,
whoever the next chief executive of the
Premiere League to come in and decide
not to take the 9 billion pounds check
that is usually on the table for the
global distribution of its rights.
So if I just end on that note,
which is are things changing his death?
There's cool things happening
in the market right now.
There's lots of different
broadcasters doing cool things,
but ultimately so long as that money
funnel continues because funds and
subscribers are subscribing
to those channels,
then that money flow will
continue throughout the game
and players will probably
be paid significant amounts because they
are that good and because the clubs can
afford it.
So on that note,
I think I'll probably say thank you
for listening and happy to answer any
questions.
[inaudible]
what's the strangest thing that you've
seen in a player's employment contracts
with the club? Like a
clause or some sort of, um,
I haven't seen any would like totally
bizarre things that I'm thinking.
Oh my gosh,
that's just really weird.
But there's lots of publicized ones that
I've put in the book. Rarely. So, um,
if I talk about a few of them,
um,
and this is just what's being
reported in the press really. Um,
so Neil Rodnick who was
an ex Liverpool play,
I'm supposed player back in
the day who um, uh, you know,
I think could Devonia really played
center but because he was quite a big guy,
but you know,
he scored a great goal.
I remember in the [inaudible] nine
new game when he went, um, uh,
towards the end of his career
it's a particular club. Um,
the report was that they put a way,
a weight clause in his contract that if
he went over a certain weight he would
be fined or his wages would
be reduced by certain limit.
Another clause which, um, I read
about, which was Stefan Schwartz,
he was a Swedish international player.
He moved to Sunderland and apparently
there was a clause which said he,
Sunderland had read somewhere that one
of the things that always wanted to do
was to go to space.
So Sunday and apparently puts a clause
in saying during your time as our club,
you are not allowed,
you're prohibited from going into space.
And there was another one
which is from a Liverpool plan,
next level plus digging could be on to
be, he was a Norwegian International. Um,
he, uh, his father was I
think an Olympic skier and uh,
Liverpool ensured that there was a
clause in which he said he couldn't ski
during the time that
he was Liverpool Fund.
All of a player obviously
for obvious reasons really.
And there is that is quite standard
clause that you can't be anything.
It hasn't just for the obvious reasons
that you probably hurt yourself.
Just quick question about the yeah.
The boots stuff that you put up as well.
I've got a good friend actually works
for one of the big two and d. Um,
he was saying about the,
one of the biggest challenges he sites
we're working with some of the players he
looks after five premier
league clubs I think, um, is,
is their egos and not their personalities.
And they all want things for free,
even though they own,
you know, mega money.
So I suppose my question is around
expectations. Do you, do you,
how do you deal with expectations?
Were players and with, with big ego,
well not everybody has got big acres
and brushing everybody puts, um,
yeah. How, how'd you deal with kind
of what those expectations were,
players and those, you know, big players.
Are you talking about, uh, W in terms
of boot gears or just generally?
Just generally? Yeah, I suppose
it's quite difficult to manage.
Um, simple truth is that, um,
of the players that I have close
relationships with and literally it's,
it's hilarious and cool as a football fan,
they'll just what's up you and say
hello and literally I'm giving book
recommendations to one player who's
interested in like just expanding is
expanding his,
um,
a repertoire of reading at the moment
because I've lived through a weight trips
and has got lots of time
on his hands. Um, but the,
the majority of players that I end
up having good relationships with,
the guys that want to know
the detail is the truth.
And usually in my experience the players
that want to know the detail of the
most switched on to understand
the way things work.
The players that may be don't are the
ones that I'd be like just leave it and
let the lawyer do it, let the account
and do it. Let the agent do it.
However is that,
that's absolutely fine too,
but usually I don't like to call it pre
Madonnas days is actually because maybe
they're not as educated as they need as
as the team around the need to give them
to make sure they understand what they
need to be doing on a daily basis to get
by is the truth and what I try
and do and lots of the time,
just to flip it onto the positive
is that every time a new player,
even if it's a young player especially
comes into the office to say hello or
helping them with the deal.
My Dad was like, look,
just give me half an hour with
the agents and the player.
I just want to talk you through
particular things I think are going to be
important for the next deal. For the
next endorsement deal you're signing.
Think about what you're doing on Twitter
or in store or snap or Tinder. Um,
literally because you know,
everybody has a phone,
everybody has a video,
everybody wants to catch someone out
doing something they shouldn't do,
who's famous. That's the
truth. Unfortunately,
that were living at the
moment players 20 years ago.
We're in a much in a way and much more
privileged position that it can have gas.
We'll probably get to wear it a lot
more stuff that players can't do now.
So that's almost the point,
which is I'm trying to just to
flip and pivots the narrative,
which is get players better educated as
to what the needs to be doing so they
can make more informed decisions.
Always players would do things wrong.
That was fallible as as us. Um, we just,
I think people are just like a bit of
Shard and Freud of where famous person
who's earning a lot of
money to something stupid.
Just wondering how you manage your
client's expectations when you're dealing
with someone who,
so for example,
a player that is injury prone and
you're going to see that in the boot
sponsorship deals and then
their appearances, a lot
of that is tied to Dapper,
you know, their parents is
and how you deal with that.
It's a really good one.
Um,
it depends how you classify
injury prone is the truth.
Now either you do one of
two things as an agent,
you can strategize beforehand to say,
right,
we've got three boot deal
offerings on the table.
The retainer amount is
this amount for this club.
So for this particular manufacturer we
think an estimate that because over the
last three seasons the players played
25 games per season because either
injuries or form,
whatever it is,
we need to try and get to this number
with this amount of appearances that we
think we can get for the
player of the season.
So in a way it's a reverse
engineering of the, um,
the contractual matrix in
order to make sure that we,
that you can get the player over the
line saying this is the amounts that you
may have,
but you're probably going to own it and
decimal because of the amount of games
you're going to play.
And ultimately what can sometimes happen,
which can help is on the
appearance side watch.
But it didn't quite touch
on if you're savvy enough,
what you can actually say to
the boot manufacturers to say,
we're only going to classify
a as particular competitions.
Because if you're an elite
athletes elite footballer,
you're probably less likely to
play an FAA cup and League Cup.
I'm more likely to playing
Champions League and Premier League.
So what you would try and do if you're
the elite agent elite player act agent
acting for elite player, you
try and exclude the, the,
the cup competitions to try and ensure
that if appearance is defined as 80% of
those games, you're more likely to
be able to hit those benchmarks.
[inaudible].